hey yo Shaq what's your favorite toy
yo yo
hey yo Shaq what's annoying what kind of
toy is annoying because you got to
untangle this a lot
I want to dedicate this song to Philip
Arthur Harrison because he was the one
who took me from a boy to a man
oh dude a trivia
[Music]
wow
yo yo I want to dedicate this song to
Philip Arthur Harris so well spoken dude
so I would like to dedicate this song
like not hip-hop at all and then also
says yo-yo and word up so soon next to
each other
yo yo one I wanted to take this song
wow that's super imposing from a boy to
a man so as far as I'm concerned not
rapping he's my father
[Music]
as far as I'm concerned in the first 20
seconds of our hip-hop song is unreal
dude as far as I'm concerned
Cincy yeah
yeah my biological didn't bother
yo yo yo yo I want to dedicate this song
well spoken
[__] wow that's the logic song Why did
that show up that's so weird
yeah hell yeah dude here we go
[Music]
[__] 90s
dude
I
just this straight up declaration
dude are you
four bars just of science
fit
Phil is my father
[Laughter]
[Music]
Phil is my father bam also Phil dude
here's Phil when he heard it that's good
holy [__] dude we gotta we gotta
holy [__]
[Music]